excuse me coming through excuse me
coming through coming through
Ryan's here Ryan's here that's right get
up get over here right so we're gonna
watch the trailer today I'm Ryan by the
way this is Dan and Elissa I don't let
you say your name
silent reactions from here on yeah
called it we're gonna watch the trailer
the final trailer supposedly for dawn of
the Planet of the Apes did you guys see
the first one though bus friended no
because some there's something about
those CGI
Apes that severely creeps me out and I
don't know what it is I can't really put
a finger on it but I just I get
heebie-jeebies well I don't think you're
supposed to that's it's okay to react my
way to it but you should still watch the
movie really sheet it's okay it's okay
it's good good it's good I haven't okay
the only one I ever saw was the original
remake oh the remake with Tim Burton's
version I don't have a Marky Mark in it
right yeah you are I thought in theatres
is so long ago yeah that was so you saw
the worst one first yeah I don't know
I've never seen any other so I have
nothing - that one's considered the
worst one it's super confusing it's
really bad I have nothing I don't like
it there guilty pleasure I'm like it's
kind of fun come on [ __ ] Smeagol over
here is great I'm Andy Serkis 8 yeah he
plays the ape in this movie Oh does he
hood into the mat get ready to be hated
if it's motion capture it Smeagol no
yeah Andy Serkis did and everyone
thought I should have got it an Academy
Award nomination for everyone but a lot
of only that guy I mean the guy is
amazing like the way he moves is like
not human
no that's why they hired him to play
non-human people I see that now it comes
full circle it's a it's a circle is Andy
Circle this
oh boy sorry
just a quick inulin okay so uh we're
gonna watch this trailer I'm excited to
see it I love the first couple trailers
I've seen so far and I love the Rise of
the Planet of the Apes James Franco hell
yeah not in this one oh that is so
creepy it's awesome effects man
I still want this to be like Game of
Thrones but with Abe's seek Carrie
Holman that's any circus creepy that's
the old Jackson no that's what makes
them stronger oh sweet oh hey bears
particulars
it's our only chance for peace
yeah [ __ ] I love Gary oh she's so fake
man like you Caesar love humans more
than Apes is the antagonism Oh Gary
Oldman why hey mister bro man also Oh
what oh shoot that was deceptive
there's always that one person
quintessential trailer reaction Wow how
are this many Apes available I want type
of a place it's I'm asking questions
my friend
what Wow
that's anyone else just get chills I did
I'd I have like serious like yeah it's
like an awesome oh dude oh my god that
looks amazing
actually I would definitely see that
still still a little bit creepy but
actually looks like a legitimately
really amazing movie those are some of
my favorite sci-fi stories where it's
like genuinely a moving picture at the
same time oh wow me and like having the
thrills you know it's such like that
seems like a moral battle you know like
you're gonna get caught up in a more
like what would you actually do in that
situation you know kind of deal yeah I'd
be friends of the apes yeah there was a
monkey riding a horse too bad for me
exactly it was an ape riding a horse I'm
sorry there was an ape riding a horse
with two m4 assault rifles it was the
best thing about receiving my money
that's funny is like it's believable you
know yeah you totally buy all this like
really if you tell someone like the
concept sounds a little silly but then
when you watch it you're like I'm buying
every moment oh yeah I mean if there
wasn't if the first movie didn't happen
if the rise of the planet of apes didn't
happen this would make absolutely no
sense no I'm excited to see this man and
I'll [ __ ] damn Andy Serkis he he
knows how to bring these it's cool
because this character is like cuz he
did King Kong after gone but he couldn't
speak his King Kong but in this now you
know he's back in the ape form is he
actually is they actually voicing Caesar
in this yeah he does the motion capture
that's great Oh interesting
oh okay totally down totally down dan
and I mainly do our games together
that's why he doesn't know these facts
like how we do guys like how we do cuz I
never watched a movie [ __ ] yeah when
i got mario i only played my mari people
like come outside watch ghostbusters
with us I'm like no why would you do
that when you have Mario Georgie
outside I don't know after I will be
there
come outside let's watch ghostbusters
outside anyway guys if you're if you're
new to the channel you click this button
to subscribe dad's got his gaming
channel over here that cyber Channel and
Alyssa just passed a thousand
subscribers Alyssa be crazy yeah so yeah
they're gonna be on the channel a lot
and they already have been
and it's gonna continue so if you don't
like them just so much the videos
they're featured in is that okay if I
say that guys um yeah well what happened
to videos I guess you don't like me on
send me a cookie
Scott Walker he said Ryan gives Scottie
Walker a shout-out because I've been
watching before he got 10k followers
whoa not all cocky and [ __ ] man cos pure
flooding confidence [ __ ] also do a
review on a review on the equalizer
it looks dope Oh check thanks dude love
your channel thank you Scott Walker
you're black
I got another black friend oh look at
you
diversifying that friend portfolio I'm
really establishing I'm not a racist I'm
not a racist I love you Scott was really
enthusiastic about the african-american
community yeah mm-hmm fun fact I
recently beginning in two black girls a
lot lately if you're a black girl you
watch this channel [ __ ] let me know
I'm like being dead serious even black
chicks have been a really [ __ ]
unappealing Nathan Legaspi I want a
shout-out okay feel like it's in Captain
okay no caps I know why are you being so
loud Nathan why you [ __ ] cuz he
started he started riding it you know
from the computer but then his hot
pocket was ready so he started like
backing up to like try to like grab it
so it's like him shouting across from
his kitchen oh it's like this it's like
this okay sure sorry is that a bit much
gonna that's right well actually uh real
fast you know I we've been climbing a
little bit
anything but recently uh Maria and I
were clowning on someone during a
subscriber shoutout we were just having
fun we love this guy no good arguments
and he got pretty offended and I am so
sorry dick did not mean to cross the
line man
I can't recall exactly what I said now
well I saw her comments and I was like
oh I kind of went a little far didn't I
it's tough yeah apology dude all the way
sorry and thanks for letting me take the
time to do that buddy and hopefully we
didn't offend you - boom Gompers shut up
please and make a rap of me alright is
gonna bus to be uh I can totally be
bucks I got this right you get
background vocals whenever you're
feeling gloom you can think about boom
you want to go boom boom boom and here
we go when I one day be your groom boom
Gompers I'm gonna wear these Stoppers
you want to shout out you safe please oh
geez wouldn't you just leave you wanna
come up to me and you want another shout
out well how about this shout out you
come out here and here we're gonna go
I'm gonna sprout like a little flower
you wanted me to make a rap over you let
go this rap is for you to remix boom
yeah what